will smith is one of the most powerful
actors in hollywood who's been ranked by
forbes as the
most bankable star worldwide he went
from being a great student but refusing
to apply for college because he wanted
to
rap to becoming one of the most powerful
actors in hollywood
whose films have grossed over 7.5
billion dollars
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best will smith and my take on his top
10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be prepared
the being prepared for the next
thing is so wildly
critical um i think life in general
is rise and fall everything is rise and
fall
and there's been a couple times in my
life where i got caught
um holding on to
the last wave while it's while it's
dying
oh i have a good quote for that yeah i
have a casey neistat quote
which is like that tar i don't even he
probably didn't make this up but tarzan
can't get to the next branch if he
doesn't let's go
absolutely that's exactly the same
philosophy yep absolutely and
you've got to be when you're grabbing
that first one and you're holding it
it's going to be there it's fantastic
but you gotta
know that you're gonna have to let go at
some point because the same thing that
saved your life
if you hang on it'll kill you rule
number two take responsibility
taking responsibility accepting
responsibility
is not an admission of guilt
you're not you're not admitting that
you're
at fault taking responsibility is a
recognition
of the power that you seize when you
stop
blaming people it's not like you're
letting somebody who wronged you off the
hook
like taking responsibility is an act of
emotional
self-defense taking responsibility
is taking your power back rule number
three
improve lives the thing is um
um you know when i when i started i had
you know all these grand ambitions of
what i wanted to be
and what i wanted to do and you know i
want to be the biggest movie star in the
world
um so i studied that and i worked out
and i got my body crazy and i did
you know just got my head around um
doing everything i could do
to be the biggest movie star in the
world you know
and then i had a taste of that and i
realized that even though i had achieved
all those things
on the inside i was still that same
insecure little boy
that was trying to prove something you
know to
to you know girls that had cheated and
to my father
and all of that and that you can't
achieve your way
out of your you know childhood wounds
and traumas you can't fake it you can't
fake it right so then i made the shift
and what i realized is that the only
sustainable mission
um throughout your whole uh existence is
to improve lives
and as soon as i made the shift in my
mind from trying to be big and trying to
have money and trying to be popular to
making sure that i improved lives every
step of the way on this earth then all
of a sudden
i started experiencing healing you know
and alfonso was one of those people that
was right there with me
making that transition from product and
winning
to love and people rule number four be
thankful
it's like everybody was sitting
at home looking at their devices
right when what felt like a new atrocity
to some people
but was happening over and over again
for african americans and for this to
happen in this time for the whole world
to see what we've been saying
for hundreds of years yes my grandmother
taught me to
try to be thankful for these
times and these opportunities to try to
be thankful for your pain
you know and we are in a circumstance
that we've never been before
the entire globe has stood up
and said to the african-american
people we see you and we hear you
how can we help we've never been there
before
also if you want to learn to have more
self-love and learn from leaders in the
black community check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below you know i've never
seen myself as particularly talented
where i excel is i'm willing to die
in the process of acquiring skill i look
at the world through a lens of comedy
right so my natural reaction is always
no matter when something happens and i
can't even help it
it's why is that funny my children the
most important thing
is that they be encouraged to fully and
thoroughly
be themselves rule number five go out on
your terms
it's funny i learned a really valuable
lesson in this right because the
um the the network
wanted to do one more season of
the fresh prince and i remember i was
considering i was going to do
one more season of the fresh prince and
we had we've done an episode of
something with
john amos and john amos came to me said
hey man listen
he's like don't overstay your welcome
on on tv he was like you're doing
great stuff he's like you do not want to
get canceled in the middle of a season
it's like go out on your terms the way
that you want to go out be able to say
goodbye
to your fans don't get caught okay yeah
that's good advice and then
so this was the sixth season and i had
an opportunity to do one more season but
i was feeling like
the quality wasn't necessarily
going to stay up and i decided to to
end the show in the in the sixth season
rule number six
stay true to yourself can you talk about
advice that you're happy you didn't take
at some point in your careers oh man
yeah this one yeah sorry mom
um one of the most critical
uh for me and and um
you know it was uh it was 1986
um and girls ain't nothing but trouble
came out in in june so i had a i had a
record out
a month before i graduated from high
school
right so first song it was at pretty
much just in
philly and and you know dc
jersey it hadn't expanded yet um
but it was time for me to start applying
to college
and um and you know my mother is a
serious uh you know educational
disciplinarian it's like education was
everything for her
and she could tell that i was kind of
feeling like maybe i didn't want to go
to college
and you know she told me that you know
if i didn't go
to college that i was throwing my life
away
and and it's like i i understood what
she was saying but that that just wasn't
true for me
you know that wasn't true for me at the
time and i wanted to take a shot at my
art i wanted to take a shot at the music
and you know so my father
convinced my mother that i would have a
year they would give me a year
where i would be able to pursue the the
music
and then if in a year i hadn't made
anything happen
that that i would go back to to college
um
and in that year uh we were nominated
and we won the the first grammy ever
given
rule number seven don't be consumed by
rage
for me it comes down to you know after
you get beyond the rage
rage is is justified
under oppression it also can be really
dangerous
you got to be careful not to be consumed
by your
own rage yeah you know and that's
something that i've worked
really hard on and what i loved about
the peaceful protest
it's like peaceful protests put up a
mirror
to the demonic imagery of your
oppressor and the more still
you are in your peaceful protest the
more clear
the mirror is to the oppressor
for the world to see and for them to see
themselves
you know so i was really encouraged by
how powerfully this generation
was able to hold that mirror rule number
eight
hone your skills you differentiate
though between talent and hard work
absolutely i've never really viewed
myself as particularly talented i view
myself as you know slightly above
average in talent
where i excel is ridiculous sickening
work ethic you know while the other
guy's sleeping i'm working
while the other guy's eating i'm working
while the other guy's making love
well i mean i'm making love too but i'm
working really hard at it
so when the phone rings that you have an
alarm goes off since denzel washington
right now is hooking up
you got to go ahead right now right you
know
for me man it's it's like the the
separation of talent
and skill is one of the the the greatest
misunderstood concepts for people who
are trying to excel who have dreams that
want to do things
talent you have naturally skill is only
developed
by hours and hours and hours of beating
on your craft
and you know for me it's i feel like i
have a relationship with the audience
they agree
that they're going to go in droves and i
agree that every time they go it's going
to be better
than the last time so i think that's
part of the the relationship and i'm
gonna hold up my part as long as they
keep holding up theirs
rule number nine maintain your
relationship with yourself
i think the the important thing is there
there's there's one relationship that
you have to maintain and that's the one
with you
right and it's like if if you're not
loving you if you're not taking care of
you
everything and everybody is second to
you taking care of you can you come back
tomorrow
you need to let that breathe
and when when you have bad relationships
and and when things go wrong which they
which they always will
it's like you know me and jada be going
at it me and me and my kids
you know there's heavy debates around
things a lot but
first and foremost when you are steady
and calm
in yourself it makes it easier to manage
the insanity that other people
are going to bring to you because like
as soon as somebody else is off the hook
if you respond to off the hook with off
the hook the relationship's done yeah
you know so it's like taking taking care
of you centering yourself
the airline's got it right put your mask
on first before attempting to assist
others
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun should we do that
we got we got our drone drone box
yeah yeah that's a tiny one though i
love that
yeah it's easier to travel with and less
people give you
you can still take your fingers off yeah
all the way
lose a finger
social team social team that's jazz
don't put your eye out there
no oh
don't put your hand in there
[Music]
i got it don't put the [ __ ] you gotta
calibrate yeah
[Music]
now i've got a special bonus clip from
will on how to explore
and experience that i think you're gonna
enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know how can you better maintain
your relationship with yourself
what are you gonna do let me know put it
down in the comments below and if you
made it this far in a video you're still
here watching i want to celebrate you
because believe nation we don't just
watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action immediately after watching this
video give me a hashtag
down in the comments and tell me where
you're from because i want to celebrate
you i'm curious if it lets you i think
the obvious answer is yes but like
you're expressing your own ideas
absolutely more often than if you're
being directed yes absolutely and and
because it's
um it's not really uh directed
per se it's a you know it's you know
sort of half
capturing real life um uh
i i shoot everything now so what i find
is it makes me explore
and experience in ways that i wouldn't
have if i wasn't going to shoot it
right you know we get into cities you
know
we we get into you know seoul uh
korea and i'm exhausted
uh but i know mlma is doing
something so i want to you know want to
go now it actually
makes me get out of the bed and go and
explore and experience and
and meet people you know even this time
with you and doing this
press conference at the youtube space
it's like
um it's an opportunity i wanted to meet
with you i wanted to sit with you i
wanted to hear what
you think it's like it jogs uh that
creative beast in inside of me
[Music]
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no
longer on this channel i have a
dedicated brand new channel just for
them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there